did you start in obviously you started
in atlanta stand up how old were you
when you started [ __ ] i don't know late
20s i've been doing this [ __ ] almost 20
years late 20s
i was a late comedian i didn't start 19
i started straight out of the box with
something to talk about so yeah i was
married well yeah i was married with
kids and
my kids were still in [ __ ] school wow
it was a struggle yeah you had kids
really young right miss pat yeah 14 15.
oh my god 14. yeah i was trying to get
that [ __ ] out of the way
i know this is waiting you 20 when your
[ __ ] bout broke down me
you know waiting to the correct age
society yeah yeah yeah use the [ __ ]
when you can
i'm not advocating for teenage
freighters and i say do you yeah yeah
you think it's over for me at 30 36
you think dust is coming out of my [ __ ]
who [ __ ] you excellent person
it's my girlfriend oh do you is dust
coming out of [ __ ] yeah
well there we go
[Laughter]
are you trying to get pregnant
you don't want to get pregnant i don't
know i don't think so i want to have
babies with her but i i we don't know
yet
cause when we first dated miss pat you
know i knocked her up can i say it yeah
no i got two abortions when i first
knocked off a couple guys
i'll say this you can't keep them all
but anyway
did you have abortion service back [ __ ]
yeah
ghetto dick keep you pregnant
it's i don't know any girlfriend of mine
that hasn't had one well
and you ever most women have but they
won't say it out loud oh my god [ __ ] i
know your [ __ ] we got the same [ __ ]
they went down the same village okay
you had an abortion and then they'd be
like i'm not a mama you are a mama you
just didn't keep them
so you get to celebrate mother's day too
it's not with the child
i never thought of it that way
that's true though yeah he was a mama
you just the baby exit the wrong way but
you are a mother
thank you so much we're we're we're
parents
for many years we have two ghost kids
the abortion was by you
is it worth it
having kids
it used to be worth it when there was
great tax write-off but when trump got
into office he took all that [ __ ] away
from the poor people yeah yeah and so
i'm quite sure y'all ain't in the class
when you get eic because you don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm talking about it's
called
income credit where they take your money
and give it to po [ __ ] so we
can buy flat stream tvs
that's the best way i can describe it to
people with money
so yeah it's not worth it anymore i mean
unless you just want a diaper bag on
your shoulder somebody's sucking on your
titty other than bobby
i didn't break i breastfed only my gay
daughter yeah and i just uh i have a bit
that's why i think she's gay because
i think she see this in her mouth too
soon
[Laughter]
but they really do suck the length out
of your [ __ ] titty like they'll make
one of your titties uneven yeah and i
had a really nice figure and [ __ ] and i
have these [ __ ] batman arms and
[ __ ] and i had that first baby and
proposed i've been this side since that
since the first [ __ ] i'm still
trying to lose weight [ __ ] 35
years old
i want to go back to my [ __ ] weight
like yeah yeah sixth grade
six
is that what you that's not when you
were starting though yeah no what was
the first how old were you when you
started 12. when you started banging
he was banging me
wasn't he like much older and yeah he
was 21 22 something wow
he signed the kid birth certificate too
they're going to show you they don't
give a [ __ ] about the kids come on bring
your old ass in here and sign this
birth certificate wow cause he signed
both kids bursa too i had two kids oh
[ __ ]
yeah and neither time nobody questioned
this old [ __ ] yeah he came in
there with his id that said he was old
as [ __ ] who should have been the oldest
brother not the baby daddy and signed a
birth certificate and kept on moving
mm-hmm
that's time now because i was the 80s i
had a baby 86 87 you do that [ __ ] today
they gonna drag your [ __ ] ass
i just saw a 12 year old girl get
pranked about 20 something year old mate
26 year old man they locked the mama and
his ass up oh yeah and the mama too
you know what really okay i'm a teenage
mom but this is when i really got
jealous is when they started giving
white girls a tv
what was my [ __ ] tv show
you
and it was crazy is that the first
season they were just all white girls
too yeah there wasn't a single and they
were just white girls no white girl what
they said don't happen in the community
i'm like oh excuse me at least at least
let me come in and and motivate these
[ __ ]
i'm the original teen mom yeah yeah yeah
and it was just giving out tv show i'm
like what the [ __ ] was my tv show and
they became i couldn't even get away
from
they they legit became celebrities too
like they have like they're on their
eighth season of it right oh yeah i i
watch now season of that [ __ ]
but miss pat i mean the the [ __ ] kind
of [ __ ] that you got going on your
career i'd rather have your [ __ ] than
that [ __ ] before i got tv yeah but now
look at you you you did this through
your skill yes right and your talent and
hard work i knew i had a [ __ ] ski i
was looking to make some money
but who pushed you who was like wait a
second like you got it you should
probably try it um i just i mean people
would always tell me i'm funny a
caseworker and you know i just got into
it and i was like oh you said caseworker
i had a caseworker okay i got it and um
i'm a convicted felon and so
it was for what for what for trafficking
cocaine oh okay or was selling